[Music]
fight less trying to help bring us back
together change the administration we
should be kinder to each other United as
one I would like to see a secure border
for America is for everyone to just come
together and not look at color and treat
everyone as human beings more love more
peace and to be more like a big family
as opposed to being divided be kind to
each other and stop judging we live in
scary times and it would just be a much
happier place if we could all get along
better we're so divided and so
aggressive towards both sides either
either side is just it's not it's not a
fun place to be right now I think we
should focus on on America and that
we're all interdependent amongst each
other no matter what our beliefs are and
get back to what made this country get
along and be the greatest country in the
history of the world I think that all
the wars need to stop I think that they
need to get the crime together they need
to like get the homelessness together
just come together everybody come
together like we used to years ago it's
it's ridiculous how people just
disrespect each other so I just want
people to respect each other more
and just because you don't agree with
something doesn't mean that it's wrong
we spend a little too much time focusing
on the things that we disagree on and a
lot less time on the things that we do
agree on so there's a lot of us that we
all have in common and spend a lot more
time focusing on that so our country is
a mess our future is not good at the
rate we're going we need to do something
different we need to try to work
together being united and finding common
ground for a lot of people have said
that today but um I feel like everyone
can kind of feel that right now too
everybody needs to get serious about
politics and not
feelings